You no
Security.
So sun. What
about a swa
Amazon betrootskate oko kaksamatotomoni
so no business so hens. P.
Moder customized.
So. Psy's
tasks.
Asians. Amazon
Ptroqua oaksamano taoanninitaminino
centa kosas.
Kakamawa anthropic
metahoa lipsig
crem open air open
open moderna.
Samazama Amazon betrogas.
First steps
third party modern o
oka. T
customized model.
I Amazon
immo Amazon nova you may show them
coconuts no more de ha.
moderna. Micro
light
pro premium
to you your model will take your reus.
Mata creative models gazo
seno canvas gase
senoli niko
speech to speech de sego seoonisha
nikos.
Multimodal embedding.
What So
What gazo
marskoka gazo i
AI agent yo
hoo sales
software system
to that's
not task agents.
A Summari
o te okari
so no businessingstemo okkina
gas. Application
of autonomous.
So Mazdani
agent mosa
mundi kai ni ni
bunks. Sadikohan
says. o
So that is sunny.
Action.
Matarikimo
agent fona kias.
What a yoshini sashi santotosteosar.
First step yoka
neoshogai kia hui geno
kosks.
AI agent.
Mo As.
What Asian
2 step
data kai take your slugato step
so and then it's cut them right eye
stop them. agent.
Leonardo.
Agents.
Yeah, say you study
Summa AI agents.
Not that. I
Enterprise the
same Yeah,
Amazon shopping Rufus
Amazon mobile applier
website assistants.
santo
na naga mo sake.
So so sarani
agentic AI platform
to ban marriage.
agent. Arriva
Group to the sky.
Ma to
Amazon. Amazon
is sins
services.
Amazon storehonimotoskira
o
B Amazon
A De
Uh ok
Oh. Amazon.
a Hi.
no marketing.
So. document.
Quitskiko
sitski.
I. Hi
The. Hi.
Hi. The.
The. Hi
Dessa.
Hi. to.
ok
sits
in. You.
Hi. Ma.
Yeah. That's it
So. agent.
Nannimonoyzaka skate osteoskinaigai
no nanze monoegento esogo
yaretsudekan
nakoto nato
no kaiga mahokanyo no kibokakao
you know zukashkustes.
So. agent.
Uh. Mass
custom so it's a data source.
So. lifting.
A. A
bone.
architecture. gay
men.
Amazon. bendgamiy
component nae koko
skis.
The. browser.
So she's identity.
memory memory memory. So.
Do you know quino madeno agent to redo
queso kinode tatsutahikinosa.
So. So
ok
ok.
computing. ya.
no ok
no management.
So. Hi
msu. enterprise.
So. presentation.
A. architecture.
database.
Hi ok
ok. So.
So. So.
So. innovation.
Hi kiss
my agent
to sky.
The. no.
announce. ok
ok ok
yo.
So. So.
so yoga
ok
no gas.
manager. So.
Hi. So
pata.
A. I.